[Musique]
attention restez bien jusqu'à la fin de
cette vidéo j'ai une annonce à couper le
souffle à vous faire salut dans ma
dernière vidéo on a parlé d'hypnose
médicale et à un moment j'ai dit ce truc
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez j'aime
bien expérimenter les choses par
moi-même pour mieux les comprendre et
donc pour mieux les expliquer vous voyez
venir du coup il me reste plus qu'à
trouver un truc douloureux à me faire
faire et bon donc aujourd'hui je vais
tester moi-même l'hypnose médicale mais
comme j'ai pas non plus envie de me
faire opérer juste pour ça j'ai trouvé
un truc douloureux à me faire faire pour
voir si ça marche
voilà comment ça va se passer j'ai réuni
une équipe de chocs Sarah le chapraïs
artiste tatoueuse ultra stylée
je vous mets son instinct dans la
description franchement aller voir ça
d'ailleurs restez bien jusqu'au bout
parce que l'annonce que je vais faire ça
la concerne aussi et Adrian chaboche
médecin hypnothérapeute ultra compétent
aussi
je vous mets son insta dans la
description franchement aller voir ça le
plan je me fais tatouer le même motif
sur les deux genoux le premier comme ça
normal sans rien et le deuxième sous
hypnose comme ça après on compare allez
c'est parti
ok c'est parti je suis en route pour le
salon de tatouage de Sarah
donc aujourd'hui elle me fait un genou
sans rien sans hypnose pour pouvoir
comparer de façon efficace
et puis évidemment on fait pas le on
fait pas les deux genoux le même jour
parce que sinon avec les endorphines du
premier tatouage etc difficile de faire
la différence entre ce qui vient des
endorphines ce qui vient de l'hypnose
donc on fera le deuxième genou avec
l'hypnose un autre jour plus tard dans
une semaine
[Musique]
on y va
et j'étais en général je fais vachement
diversion quand je suis en train de me
faire tatouer je pense à autre chose
discute machin et tout et du coup j'ai
pas mal et en fait là je crois que le
fait de me concentrer sur ma douleur
pour
je me concentre dessus pour essayer de
me rappeler la différence bah du coup je
la ressens vachement plus conscientise
la douleur en fait plus que
[Musique]
ça va
bouger
[Musique]
voilà mais sinon faut est très très cool
je tiens à te dire que je ne prends
aucun plaisir à te faire mal
ok on est ok on est exactement 5 jours
après la première séance je vous ai pas
fait de débrief je vous ferai tout ça à
la fin parce que ça me paraît plus plus
judicieux de faire un truc comparé une
fois que tout est terminé là je
m'apprête à aller retrouver Sarah pour
la deuxième séance pour le deuxième
genou
mais donc cette fois avec Adrian avec le
docteur chaboche
l'hypnothérapeute donc qui va me faire
une induction pour me mettre dans les
meilleures conditions pour pour
supporter le mieux possible la douleur
liée au tatouage et puis ce qui est
intéressant pour vous mais surtout pour
moi parce que là je suis quand même
directement les deux pieds dedans les
deux genoux dedans c'est de voir si ça
marche c'est de voir si ça fait vraiment
diminuer la douleur donc l'avantage
c'est que là maintenant j'ai un point de
référence le tatouage sur le genou je
sais ce que ça donne je savais pas avant
donc là deuxième motif exactement
similaire au premier mais sur l'autre
genou sous hypnose
et on se retrouve après pour discuter de
tout ça c'est vraiment super beau c'est
une journée idéale pour se faire
hypnotiser je pense
[Musique]
qu'il y avait bien trouvé ce point de
content est-ce que tu penses que tu
pourrais
pendant la une minute éventuellement et
c'est déjà de le retrouver juste le fait
qu'on soit ensemble
comme ça on mettait un petit déclic en
fonctionnement quasiment comment tu peux
faire
exactement la position de la main
parfait
voilà exactement
c'est intéressant ce qu'on va tout de
suite la capacité de concentration que
tu as continue c'est très bien
[Musique]
visualise bien on programme bien dans la
tête tout ce qui est ici
ou si on avait vraiment dans la main si
on avait la main pour contrôler tout
donc on se concentre plus en plus sur la
main
donc on sait qu'on a à cet endroit la
petite sensation du démarrage cette
piqûre de démarrage
et correspondait ensemble et de
paupières qui est vraiment tellement
maintenant
[Musique]
que toi tu veux sentir vraiment une
lumière
sont tellement bien de faire des yeux
ça se passe sans effort
on va faire un nouveau vérification à
nous deux comme un enfant m'avait fait
la différence qui s'est installé
[Musique]
on connaît tous les deux de Noël France
tous les quatre d'ailleurs
même si c'est tout prévu qui
n'appartient à vraiment 91
et ton esprit aime se retrouver
[Musique]
à des images se confondent et avec
d'autres sensations
la bière qui a fait qu'on est passé de
l'autre côté
que on entend sans scène et on est
tellement plus loin
on a partagé entre à la fois se sent pas
en même temps
reprendre la main par hasard
tranquillement comment on revient de
loin on fait tranquille
voilà le petit réel justement dans le
corps
donc tout assez
[Applaudissements]
cool il faut tout ce que tu sais
je pourrais respirer
en marque on est tout engourdi ça c'est
assez typique
vraiment engourdi d'une manière un peu
différente que quand on rêva si on est
un peu
quand on vient de Bon Temps d'hypnose et
cette soif d'engourdissement on sait
qu'on était là on sait qu'on est parti
mais quand on revient on se rend compte
qu'on était vraiment parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
25 degrés
vous remercie d'avoir voyagé avec la
compagnie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
franchement je trouve
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qu'on retient de tout ça
première séance plutôt classique en
terme de douleur
plutôt un peu plus douloureuse que ce
que j'ai connu d'avoir parce que le
genou c'est douloureux ensuite parce que
vous avez vu je me suis vraiment focus
sur la douleur pour bien l'imprimer pour
pouvoir la comparer avec la séance avec
hypnose donc je pense que le fait de se
concentrer sur la douleur ça fait plus
mal en fait et sinon après vous avez vu
je pense que ça parle de soi-même
douloureux et puis la jambe qui saute
toute seule de manière réflexe assez
régulièrement deuxième séance du coup
avec hypnose comme vous avez vu ben je
bouge pas d'un poil j'ai pas eu du tout
c'est sursaut c'est sursaut reflex et
puis en termes de douleur ben je crois
que c'est assez probant les images
parlent de parle d'elle-même
[Musique]
donc c'est pas que ça fait pas du tout
mal c'est juste qu'on a pas l'impression
de ressentir la douleur de la même façon
[Musique]
du coup alors c'est marrant il y a
vraiment il y avait il y a des moments
où
je sentais vraiment rien comme une
anesthésie locale quoi il y a des
moments où je sentais mais je sais pas
comment dire
c'était douloureux je savais que j'avais
mal mais c'était pas un problème en fait
il y avait aussi ce truc de par moment
je savais que potentiellement ce que tu
es en train de faire ça faisait mal mais
c'est comme si j'étais
à côté comme si j'observais le truc sans
vraiment ressentir de la douleur mais
tout en sachant que ça faisait mal c'est
vraiment typique typique de la
description de l'excellence de l'hypnose
les patients qui sont au bloc avec qui
on fait de la des anesthésies sous
hypnose est écrivent la même chose c'est
vraiment très tronche parce que le
patient la personne va te dire vraiment
je sais que j'ai mal je sens que j'ai
mal mais je suis à côté
spécifique de l'hypnose ensuite autre
truc impressionnant quand même on passe
d'une séance d'une heure 40 à une séance
de moins d'une heure
je la trouve vachement plus détendu il y
a enfin ça rentre enfin il y a ce truc
ou aussi je pense que ta peau était déjà
en meilleure condition parce qu'il y
avait pas tout ce côté stress et puis tu
étais vraiment concentré sur toi mais
même moi en fait tu vois le fait de
enfin de me dire que tu as pas mal et
que je peux y aller en fait que je peux
mais moi ça me fatigue là je suis pas du
tout fatigué alors qu'il y a des séances
il y a des fois
qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme autre option
admettons pour ce type de pièce là qui
avait plus d'une heure de réduction et
après moi je me débrouille tout seul
ouais là je l'ai je suis resté parce que
mais on allait pas convenu du moment que
ça tiens donc là si c'est pas convenu je
peux pas me barrer sur la corde de
clients en disant ça c'est pas possible
dans le dans le cadre tout à fait
imaginer que moi je viens faire
l'induction
je te mets dans cet étage je vais te
donner quelques tips entre guillemets
pour entretenir l'État comme j'ai fait
sur en fait tu fais des cercles ou tu
parles tu étais mal tu reviens puis tu
repars tu vois donc une image une image
une sensation une image ainsi de suite
elle s'échauffe sur lesquelles je suis
revenu de manière rébarbative parce que
à ce moment-là le cerveau comprend le
mouvement il le fait tout seul donc si
j'avais eu à partir
je leur ai dit voilà maintenant tu peux
continuer tu vas faire ça tu sentiras à
quel moment tu reviens tu repars c'est
normal etc on va le codifier tu te
l'appropries tu continues et tu aurais
pu me faire genre j'aurais pu venir te
voir à ton à ton cabinet et tu aurais pu
m'apprendre à me débrouiller tout seul
c'est un peu moins confortable parce que
il y a ce temps de se rapprocher le
temps qu'on a fait l'un d'ancrage au
tout début je t'ai demandé de bien
cartographier la pièce et ça c'est pour
vraiment en fait se mettre à l'aise et
se dire que on est là c'est ton endroit
pour toi aujourd'hui pour cette pièce
donc ça faut le configurer avant si on
fait une séance en dehors du salon c'est
plus confortable si on le fait dans le
salon au moment de monter mais
effectivement en dehors oui en tout cas
voilà expérience probante résultat
vraiment impressionnant truc super
positif pour tout le monde que ce soit
pour Sarah la tatoué donc tatoué dans
des meilleures conditions me disait
qu'elle était moins fatiguée après la
séance qu'elle l'est d'habitude ou pour
moi évidemment parce que pareil j'étais
souvent après une séance de tatouage on
est un peu un peu fatigué un peu c'est
un peu éprouvant physiquement là moi je
pète le feu et d'ailleurs parce que là
on est quelques jours après avec le
recul cicatrisation beaucoup plus facile
aussi côté gauche c'est à dire côté avec
hypnose que côté droit c'est-à-dire côté
classique sans sans hypnose c'est quand
même assez troublant là encore ça mérite
de ce de se renseigner et je vais pas me
je vais pas me priver je vous tiendrai
au courant évidemment si ça vous si ça
vous intéresse mais ce qu'on sait c'est
que le stress ça ralentit la CICAT
parce que quand on stresse on sécrète
des substances comme la cortisol
l'adrénaline etc et ça on sait que ça
une influence négative sur la
cicatrisation la douleur c'est une forme
de stress c'est une forme de stress
physique si vous voulez donc possible
que ce soit ça qui joue encore une fois
ça me paraît intéressant de se
renseigner un peu plus là-dessus avant
de partir la fameuse annonce la fameuse
annonce que je vous ai vendues dès le
départ et vous allez voir que ça
concerne aussi Sarah il y a un truc que
vous avez peut-être pas remarqué au tout
début de cette vidéo je vous remontre
ce patch voilà en fait je lance une
collection capsule chez la marque crève
que vous connaissez que vous connaissez
sûrement c'est une marque qui travaille
beaucoup avec des tatoueurs et des
tatouages pour pour les visuels et bah
allez sur leur site vous allez repérer
un petit onglet dans ton corps et sous
cet onglet vous allez trouver ma
collection capsule 4 t-shirts des patchs
en édition hyper limitée cela ils seront
pas réédités les t-shirts on sait pas
encore
en tout cas je suis hyper content le
mieux je pense que c'est que je vous
mette le petit spot que j'ai préparé
parce qu'il y a toutes les infos dedans
en tout cas n'hésitez pas collection
capsule DTC chez crève salut salut
écoutez-moi bien parce que j'ai un truc
énorme à vous annoncer et là vous vous
demandez
[Musique]
vous pourrez retrouver les patchs là-bas
bon bah voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui moi je file où elle Fest
retrouver Sarah Adrian le médecin qui va
y être aussi et les potes de chez crève
nous on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]